people often like to say that the rich
get richer and the poor get poorer but
in reality only one of these statements
are true in fact a study of 177
self-made millionaires found that 59% of
them had a middle-class background while
a whopping 41% came from a low-income
household despite having exponentially
fewer opportunities in the middle class
but even aside from statistics a
significant portion of the people we
look up to didn't start rich or middle
class but poor from Steve Jobs at
Sheeran and Leonardo DiCaprio to
Autosports [ __ ] JK Rowling and Oprah
Winfrey many of them have gone to
extreme lengths from money from selling
their blood to pay for college tuition
to working as a janitor and collecting
food stamps so clearly it's not a lack
of opportunity or economic power that's
holding back the middle class but then
what is
[Music]
well starting off people in the middle
class generally have too many options
having options are great but in this
case it generally leads to
procrastination and indecisiveness as
the middle class indefinitely searches
for the perfect opportunity if it's
stocks they'll say they're waiting for
the market to bottom if it's real estate
they'll say they're waiting for lower
mortgage rates and if it's starting a
business they'll say they need more
money now these are meaningful reasons
as investing in a real estate or stock
market crash can be quite lucrative but
the thing is though wealthy individuals
may become wealthier during a recession
they definitely don't wait around for
crashes to build wealth and really the
vast majority of people making such
excuses or just using these excuses to
justify a lack of action to themselves
and/or others so most of them wouldn't
even take action if the perfect
opportunity presented itself but even
for the people that would take action
the issue is that they'll likely not
tain whatever it is they aim to do
because the window of time for the quote
unquote perfect opportunity is small and
unexpectable taking a look at the crash
that just happened you can see how many
small peaks and valleys there were on
the way down that could have been
interpreted as a market bottom the truth
is not even Warren Buffett or very
Dahlia could reliably predict the bottom
but even if you did what happened to
them Walker returns would you sell when
the market reaches all-time highs again
if so you would have actually gotten a
solid 50 percent return in the past
crash but then what's the plan after
that wait another 12 years for the next
crash and hope that you can score the
bottom once again even being one day
late would cost you 10% lowering your
returns to 40% I think you guys can see
the problem with trying to time the
market even the biggest companies in the
world don't time the market the iPhone
came out right before one of the worst
recessions in history and Google was
launched to the heights of the dot-com
bubble furthermore a lot of these
companies also didn't have revolutionary
ideas either Google for example was late
to the search seen the mail scene and
the browser scene they didn't even buy
the original online video sharing
platform
which was Cheryl calm founders solid
seven years before YouTube despite not
being first at anything at the start
they have come out first in the overall
internet game evidently the excessive
options available to middle class often
hold him back as the analyst Lee search
for the perfect opportunity when studies
have shown over and over again that time
in the market is much more valuable than
trying to time the market whether stocks
real estate or starting a business
moving on the middle class is more
fearful of risk because they actually
have something to lose a lot of people
in the middle class have high-paying
jobs well into six figures and they
don't want to leave behind the safety of
that job to start a business
similarly the middle class doesn't want
to risk the money that they have slowly
saved up for years they would rather
just continue slowly save up rather than
trying to grow the money conversely low
income individuals don't have anything
to lose anything would be better than
their low income and low savings and
that brings me onto one of the most
important pitfalls of the middle class
which is that they're comfortable sure
they'd enjoy making more money or
becoming wealthy but they're for the
most part already satisfied with where
they are and don't see a need for change
they already have the house they already
have the cars and they can already
afford some fun here and there but this
is only partially true and oftentimes
the excuse the middle-class use to
continue stagnation now if you're in
this stage and enjoy your career then
there's no issue whatsoever but the fact
is that you would be in a vast minority
because according to Gallup 85% of
people hate their jobs so if you're in
the middle class and fall within this
category then whether you like it or not
money will solve a lot of your problems
maybe having more money would enable you
to finally quit the job you hate but it
doesn't even have to be that big of a
change if it's a two-hour commute that's
eating you up then money can help you
relocate close to your job or if it's
the boss or culture of your office that
you hate money would give you more
flexibility on where you work so for the
vast majority of the middle-class having
more money would it be a bigger benefit
than they would like to admit we often
see a bunch of studies showing that
after 70 or $80,000 a year the
correlation between making more money
and Happiness dies out but I think
there's an inherent flaw with
establishing such a relationship because
correlation does not show causation and
there are a variety of factors that
influence this relationship for starters
making more money comes along with more
stress and responsibility you might also
have to work longer hours and have less
time off so really it could even be
argued that the fact that the money
Happiness graph stagnates at one point
proves that making more money is making
these people happier because for most
people making more money is accompanied
by a lot of negative aspects in their
work life does being just as happy as
people making less money shows that
they're actually happier in other
aspects of their lives whether family
friends are travel and that brings me on
to the final and most important reason
the middle-class will never win from a
wealth perspective which is that the
middle-class often looks down on wealth
we often think that wanting more money
is greedy and we assure ourselves that
having more won't make us happy but
let's be real here the simple fact that
money can eliminate a job that you hate
what you'll likely spend at 30 for life
working at or over 90,000 hours to our
lifetime otherwise I'd be willing to bet
that more money would make you happier
and the dismissal of this fact is I
think the biggest downfall of the
middle-class many of us just tell
ourselves that we already have enough
and make up terrible excuses for a
stagnation like waiting for the perfect
opportunity the president or of course
baby boomers they must be it
meanwhile the poor and the rich are
always hungry for more which
continuously pushes them forward but if
you're truly satisfied with life
disregard all of this as there's nothing
wrong with that just don't be part of
the 85 percent of people who are lying
to themselves on a daily basis but
that's just what I think
drop a like if you guys agree and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one